smack that [ __ ] no don't deny my smack
yes I'm gonna get you my name is and I
abused women I'm just kidding I come
here I was just kidding let me pat your
face there we go okay Wow what are you
doing up there all right let's make our
way over here not the problem there's no
name oz problemas welcome back to a
Saturn blood cake it's not my favorite
cake but it is a good egg his King and
that's what this challenge is about
every every now and then I do a cake
video and to say no wait what am i doing
alright we denied the girl from coming
with us
you stay back you stay down there I tell
you girl Emma listen say go down here
why should I go
smack there for being there
I hate there got to make me breathe and
[ __ ] all right left low hey it's one of
those spinning things I love ya come
here
whoa no no no no you can't use psychic
on spinning things stop smacking err why
do you stop doing it why what happened
what what happened to my excellent set
up my you should see my setup it's
[ __ ] embarrassing
all right here we go I'm sorry I don't
know how long that was did you like look
at my crotch it probably wasn't looking
okay so we need to go Oh Westfield
[Music]
I'd scout not the problem jump
well I heard you jump jump down in this
game it's like don't care about anything
whoa whoa oh no oh no don't look at my
ass girl boss you're doing this aren't
you
oh no she's got a hell on me what is
this brush hatchet aah
hey there little do you need my house
smack in your face with a newt
ha ha ha that that it's too late for
slaughter how's she doing
you think it's funny I'll teach you
bunny
I changed your face it has to be a
fountain all right so another one your
friend - you want some of this oh no oh
no she's like my girlfriend oh hell no
lamp what are you doing you're a
pathetic excuse of a land
why all this so listen is there
something you want to tell me lamb then
get it out right now
all right let's go back and save the
girl sorry I'm not interested what's
going on over there should be alright
here we go
not a problem at all it could be a
problem if you think about it too much
but
all right let's smack it open ah
acaba I'm sorry I'm really professional
today I don't know I
sneaking modak well you are beautiful
you have plans for me hahaha
denied your mess smack your face and
your butt cheek
denied
start that all on the flowers back at
you mr. Marsh but that till you get sir
I think I know where the girl is
I'm not sure let's investigate
let's look at the map actually that
thing looks like a hair of a JJ I'm just
pointing it out there I don't know about
you or me but it could be of a JJ whoa
he's like I am here we got your
girlfriend
hi back off d generous that's what you
get for denying him why are they having
a party outside my girlfriend's house
back out
Kat you're nothing bite it nice to go
one in the vajayjay
whoa done drag me
Asian women can rape me baby oh no what
the hell is this
they're sucking white I don't want to
know actually ticktick hey Maya what are
you doing here
what took you so long are you serious is
she serious
this candy camera Maya what are you
doing come here I'm scared I need you a
little fatty what are you doing
all right let's play some silent
she's like what are you doing take me
down right now I let your beard it
tastes delicious
all right so you need to go back to
Westfield throw the gate are you after
me girl come here I tell you I died
about okay yeah that thing better not be
alive now I swear on my mother
yeah Mon a little higher I'm sure you
won't alert anyone
[Music]
okay good she's after us let's go to the
Westfield
and stop moaning they'll hear you
[Music]
all right so where do we go now that is
the question
wait umbrella holy [ __ ] you can use an
umbrella as a weapon yes they will fall
for my own brother powers
well if that's knock of a tree like a
problem hey did you wait did someone
follow you here
hey what are you doing well I won
tripping balls
brother power Oh power more umbrella
power that's what I'm talking about
you know know about my umbrella but now
you know that's right did you see that I
knocked over that tree I have quite the
big muscles you know we should make love
later now come on and follow me all
right which way Ola Ola Kae girl on the
cuff cuff a lot of bacon planet or a
dollar down what are you looking at
alright
I don't know you scared my dog you and I
possess umbrella power umbrella power
i'm britta power nipple
there we go there we go oh holy fight
back oh I'm pissed now umbrella power
come on you can't die no no no don't die
please don't die don't die
umbrella power is weakening I don't know
I wish it was umbrella
I feel sad now what am I going sick the
map what the [ __ ] oh I need to go
through our body oh it's behind me why
didn't you tell me huh waiting wait wait
where are you going riding
damn it ride into town
right
damn
adding
umbrella power okay if anyone knows how
to switch to third mode permanently I
would lie measure see that I was
actually in the PlayStation 3 jungle
tournament and it was Becky Stan pretty
cool stuff got third plate action first
place biggie got the first place what
the hell was that
look at her face what's wrong with it
hey it's Little Red Riding Hood is she
doing her job hopping a shepherd girl
you're gonna pray to Jesus Jesus can
help you from flying monsters reading
book ain't gonna have to be there wait
God is a book
is she that disoriented why she's
shaking what am i watching mostly who
want it I say that when it rains - mmm
that means I can go in and play video
games again
oh no oh wow he died that's sad
very dramatic sadness there I'm sure he
died No hey in the next episode don't
care alright I don't even care alright
let's I just want to know if I should
start a new one
I want a little more so you're in for a
treat
reading back that [ __ ] was that for Maya
I scared her Saiga Saiga that is an
awesome name I invented it
oh we get to place him Oh sniping
sniping mode activated
whoa that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about
oh no he's dying BAM this one is for
Oprah Winfrey that's right that's what
I'm talking about
oh oh I can sue what whoa what was that
shake the wireless control me ah to
reload alright now that it where's he
going I shoot that girl in the vjd oh
it's a boy well he's a girl now I gave
him a vajayjay there you go you can
thank me later I should become a plastic
surgeon now anyone else want a piece of
this cuz I am pretty open for suggestion
anyone just want to shout out their name
I guess I gotta use this she bought
though think or slap the stick on the
thing that works too okay all right
let's kill you oh there's so many of
them
I can't [ __ ] see it's too far away
it's too foggy I don't know should I go
down or something okay let's go down and
say hello
I feel badass I know why you they would
give you a gun in a horror
whoa what the hell was that oh no no no
no no it sees me I don't see it what is
it
what are you show yourself what the hell
is that a butterfly
you're a beautiful bucket what the hell
are you don't you all tonight didn't
iron mother-effer yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah a bucket of freaking
butterflies man I'm in third person mode
I don't even know how I did it
what is that my directions escape saves
time no well I don't even [ __ ] know
where he is
oh we're back here okay but why should
we go then
what are you doing stop breakdancing I
keep telling you you're not break down
sir profession what are you doing what
are you doing don't make me kill you
why can't you shoot ah [ __ ] me I'm
screwed
oh yeah that's a perfect time to do that
I'm so screwed I'm so scared I'm sister
why can't I I'm sorry but why can't I
Matt of a more something
now there we go
ha how you like that tell me I want to
abuse I want good reviews oh you want to
come too
that's ok I'm generous I'm Ellen
DeGeneres that's right that's my middle
name Ellen DeGeneres Felix Kjellberg all
right there you go there you got my name
girl and boy let's go over here
I'm sure it's over here
hey how you doing are you part of the
break dance competition well here you
got that is you're in Mars need more
breakdancing participants you need to
complete your objective
oh of course anyway I think that's
enough time we had today like a favorite
if you enjoyed subscribe to come abroad
today and I'll see you next episode
[Applause]
[Music]
we stop I've been to know where it